you've been watching the media today i'm
sure and you have seen that there is
violence in jerusalem
now the way the media covered this sort
of stuff is they always suggest that
it's a cycle of violence both sides are
to blame
this is because the media are ignorant
and stupid and have no expectations of
humane and decent behavior
by radicals in the palestinian community
now the vast majority of palestinians
are not people presumably who want to
engage in violence and terrorism
but there are a lot of people in that
community who do in fact want to engage
in violence and terrorism and those
people tend to occupy the highest
rungs of palestinian governmental
structures hamas runs at the gaza strip
it is an open terrorist group
islamic jihad and fatah are the other
groups that run
judea and samaria the so-called west
bank okay those groups
are terrorist groups they've been
terrorist groups for a very long time
now the pretext for all of this is the
eviction
of some palestinian families from sheikh
jarrah
from homes in shikshara okay they're
allowed to live
elsewhere they're just not allowed to
live in these particular homes because
they don't have legal deed to these
homes
there's been a string of decisions going
all the way back to 1970 by israeli
courts suggesting that people who have
the original legal deeds
to these homes have the ability to
charge rent to the people living in
homes
people haven't been paying the rent and
so now they're going to be
taken out of the homes the same way that
if you don't pay a rent in the united
states in an apartment you get evicted
it's that simple
according to ngo monitor the district
court case addressed ownership claims of
eight appellants the court found
three of the appellants are the children
and grandchildren of residents who
acknowledge the ownership of the israeli
organizations
in court proceedings in 1982. four of
the appellants claimed to have purchased
the properties in 1991
from a man named ismail but can note
they have no idea who ismail is
they can't provide any documentation for
this so literally they're just saying
some guy sold me the land and they have
no idea who it is and they can't provide
any evidence this ever happened
in october 2020 a magistrate court in
israel rejected the resident's claim
that the property had been promised to
them
by the jordanian authorities during the
years in which jordan controlled the
area
according to that particular court
decision all the witnesses were born
after 1967
or were very young at the time and
testified they heard about the jordanian
promise from an older relative so
not a single person who is currently
saying we don't have to pay rent has
any sort of legal basis for claiming
they don't have to pay rent end of story
okay so does this mean the palestinians
aren't allowed to live in shikhara
or being expelled from no shikshi is a
majority arab area
a huge number of of arabs live in east
jerusalem
a huge number of arabs live in
sheikshira there's like four houses so
why is that leading to rioting
because it is well coordinated in
advance fatah was supposed to hold
elections this is the palestinian
authority
armed military wing they were supposed
to hold elections they didn't hold
elections because they knew they were
going to lose so instead
they've decided to ram up the level of
violence
so for example may 3rd this is last week
there was a palestinian terror attack on
two israelis
and fatah posted on its facebook page
right facebook allows this sort of stuff
apparently
fatah posted it on its facebook page a
call to palestinians
to delete video of the incident from
their cctv cameras so that the
palestinian terrorists would not be
caught remember fatah is the ruling
party of mahmoud abbas the so-called
moderate
according to the fatah movement quote
our allowed people honored members of
our people we call on you to get rid of
the contents that were stored in the
security cameras of your homes
or your businesses today and not to
transfer any media content
among yourselves the facebook
page of the fatah movement also said the
fatah movement nablus branch
emphasized that resistance is a natural
right of the palestinian people against
the zionist arrogance there were three
israeli teens wounded in the shooting
attack one ended up dying
okay so that was mahmoud abbas fatah
party trying to cover for that
in the week leading up to all of these
riots there were a bunch of tick-tock
videos that were posted of palestinians
in east jerusalem beating the hell out
of jews
and which caused retaliatory violence by
wrong-minded israelis
israeli jews okay but fatah has been
pushing this for a long time so last
week for example fatah put out a video
and this video literally translated says
oh
self-sacrificing fighter make sure your
bullets hit the target
hit it hit it and it's about shooting
israelis hey this is being put on
these are the beautiful the beautiful
sounds of fatah tv
and this is the is like is the governing
party in the palestinian authority
oh self-sacrificing fighter ignite it
ignite it everywhere
so they're openly calling for violence
make sure the cannon is a fire burning
by night
make sure the israelis day does not come
it's beautiful
music right really good stuff there
meanwhile abbas's spiritual advisor his
religious affairs advisor
he explicitly says you will go to
paradise if you shoot an oppressor
his name is mahmoud al-habash okay and
somebody asks what is your opinion
if i kill an israeli and here's malcolm
she is the religious adviser to mahmoud
the head of the palestinian authority
the dictator because he hasn't had an
election in
nearly two decades
and these are open calls to violence
guys you think this rioting is
spontaneous it is not
it is not spontaneous this is all
planned
okay then there's the lie so that you
see riots in jerusalem on the temple
mount conflict on the temple mount right
this is how you normally see it in the
new york times the way that the new york
times pitches this conflict on the
temple mount breaks out
violence breaks out on tempo here's the
headline hundreds hurt in clashes
at oxen mosque as tension rises in
jerusalem really hundreds hurt in
clashes were they
they're just clashes that happen well
what if i told you
that hamas and fatah terrorists had used
al-aqsa as a staging ground in order to
ignite violence because they know the
media will cover it this way
there's been a feature of the
israeli-palestinian conflict for
literally decades at this point
all this is pre-planned this is
perfectly obvious so for example here
are some pictures we were told by the
way it's just a bunch of people
peacefully praying
inside the al-aqsa mosque now here's the
thing i have enough to the temple mount
the al-aqsa mosque is open all the time
and the only reason there are any
restrictions put on people getting up to
the temple mount is because the israeli
authorities knew that terrorists were
infiltrating the temple mount
that is literally the only reason and so
they put up some sort of fencing
and then the palestinians got mad so
they took down the fencing for two days
and then the palestinians still got mad
so it turned out it wasn't about the
fencing at all
so you have a bunch of particularly
young arab men who went up
into the al-aqsa mosque and they brought
with them giant piles of rocks
because that's what i do when i go to
synagogue i immediately bring with me
things i can throw at the cops
i like to bring guns and fireworks and
all sorts of stuff here are some
pictures of hamas in the al-aqsa mosque
you can see
just piles of rocks these broad piles of
rocks
okay this is people up on the temple
mount who are setting fires
lighting fires really enjoying
themselves up there on the temple mount
supposedly this deeply holy site i can
tell you what jews don't do at their
holy sites
and no jews in israel are using their
holy sites for this sort of activity
so far as i'm aware and if they are is
criminal under israeli law
okay these are people who are holding up
islamic jihad and hamas flags
on the temple mount and these are the
flags of terrorist groups on the temple
mount
here you have a bunch of people who are
wearing those are those red those
green headbands are hamas headbands and
they're holding up copies of the quran
and some of them are holding up weapons
it's uh it's it's good times right it's
it's good times up there on the al-aqsa
mosque
compound clearly these are people who
are there just for you know a little bit
of religious scholarship at the end of
ramadan
now again i don't think this represents
the most of the people in the
palestinian
areas who would just like to be left
alone and live their lives i think this
represents the militant wing
of these corrupt governmental bodies
that are terrorist groups
so yesterday you started to see members
of the media who are ignorant and stupid
pass around video of people chanting on
the temple mount right these are
palestinians who are chanting on the
temple mount
and they're like look at these people
resisting israel look at how they're
resisting israel
israeli oppression okay so here is the
video and then i'll tell you what
they're saying
okay as you can see in the background
the dome of the rock is again up on the
temple mount i've been up there
okay this is the okay you have probably
a thousand people
who are all chanting in unison here
young young palestinian men
so what exactly are they chanting so the
media pushed this out look at these
this beautiful active here's what
they're chanting in arabic
bomb bomb tel aviv now you may have
noticed that tel aviv is not actually
quote unquote occupied territory
tel aviv is like the first major city in
israel outside of jerusalem
so this is just terrorists who are
calling for terrorism
that's all our terrorist supporters
calling for terrorism there are a bunch
of people who put this out
and then they had to take it down if not
now put this out and then they had to
take it down because they realized that
it was promoting terrorism
man you had video from al-aqsa right
these are the clashes that the new york
times talks about
he heard clashes on the temple mount the
holy site in judaism
and the al-aqsa mosque a very holy site
for palestinians
they are using al-aqsa as a staging
ground in order to fire fireworks and
throw rocks at the israeli police
they were generating conflict because
they know the media are suckers for this
stuff
and they know that the media are always
going to blame israel in any sort of
conflict doesn't matter that
every statement from the israeli
government has been we want you to be
able to exercise your religious freedom
but you know what you're not allowed to
do
is go up there and bring rocks into the
al-aqsa mosque and chuck them at the
police
but here they were doing i mean this is
again soft bigotry of low expectations
or the full bigotry of no expectations
there are people using a mosque as a
staging ground for terrorism
there they go just firing at the cops by
the way
you should know you know how
[Music]
you know how careful the israeli police
are about not offending arabs up on the
temple mount so when i was up on the
temple mount which was in
october of 2019 when i went up to the
temple mount it was
sukkot right so it was one of the last
days of sukkot it's called hoshanaraba
we go up there you're not allowed to
pray as a jew openly on the temple mount
which by the way is an act of act like
actual discrimination
if you're an arab you can pray wherever
you want upon the temple mount if you're
a jew and you stop
and you pray then arab guards will rush
at you and they will yell at you that
you're not allowed to pray up there so
we stopped for just a moment
and we were saying prayers from our
phones right you try to make it look
like you're not praying
you say some prayers from your phone
okay and then members of these
all aksa mosque guards run up and start
screaming at people okay so people start
moving on
and one of the guys in our group had
brought along with him some
branches some willow branches one of the
ceremonies you do on hoshanah raba is
you take the willow branches and you
beat them on the ground
okay so he did that for like a second
the mishnara the israeli police
not the arabs the israeli police ran up
to him and started to arrest him
for literally taking some branches and
hitting them on the ground a bunch of
of arab women who are up there ran over
and started chanting allahu akbar
because this is th this is ground that
is so
so holy to them that jews can't be up
here et cetera et cetera okay well the
the mishira went right along with this
right they moved us all off the temple
mount
fine there are people who are
stockpiling rocks and fireworks
and weapons up there and apparently
the media think that's totally fine okay
again the media don't know anything
about this conflict and so they pretend
they know something about the conflict
and then they lie to you about the
conflict
arab students are rioting over hebrew
university one of the most liberal areas
in israel is hebrew university hebrew
you
is not a conservative organization there
are riots over there too
all of this supposedly over the eviction
of four families from shikjura
four families there are millions of
palestinians
who live in these areas four families
were evicted because they were living in
actual legally documented jewish homes
without paying rent
and there are widespread riots that is
that's what we call a pretext gang that
is a pretext
for for violence at hebrew university
this is all coordinated from above this
is coordinated by fatah it is
coordinated by hamas
and it's all culminated in
jerusalem day there are all of these
events that are packed together the last
day of ramadan
was this week and then jerusalem day
which is the day that israel
won in 67 war they won these areas of
jerusalem
there is this march that happened
through jerusalem that of course sparked
violence
because the arabs can't allow jews to
march through jerusalem which is
sovereign israeli territory can't allow
that
and then the there were there were
full-scale attacks on people who were
just driving
so there is a there is a there's
something called the jericho road which
surrounds jerusalem
there's a jewish driver who was driving
on the jericho road and he was stoned
right the palestinian youths started
throwing rocks at his car he was hitting
the head
his car went out of control you can see
his door is open as he's driving because
his door is wrenched open he was hitting
head with a rock
okay so what you're about to see in this
video is he swerves because he's lost
control of the car and then
people rush up to the car and they start
trying to drag the guy out of the car
and beat him to death with rocks
you see they're running over there and
they're throwing rocks at the driver
he he only drives him away because he
takes a a gun and he fires it in the air
a couple of times a couple of warning
shots
then the police arrive and the police
are trying to
defend this driver from being murdered
on the street
right you can see the driver is the
driver has a uh
bandage around his head you can see he's
heavily bleeding
now you can see the the label on the
back of the guy sure is mishtara he's
holding everybody off the gun
okay this is how volatile things have
gotten they've gotten this way because
they are promoted from above
because this is being promoted by fatah
and hamas they don't make a secret of it
but the media lie to you
because the media don't want you to know
what's going on there and they certainly
don't want you to know that the biden
administration
has been spending hundreds of millions
of american dollars
sending those sending that money over to
the palestinian authority
okay that that is what they really don't
want you to know is that there is
taxpayer money
going to precisely the groups it was
just restored by the by
in in violation of the taylor force act
there's money that was just restored to
these palestinian terror groups by the
biden administration
it's it's pretty absurd but again you
don't have to know anything about the
middle eastern comfort for the new york
times
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment